Music
in the future the bed I always so hope
will be a democratic elected leadership
power of people people spoil it is
feminine oh and you're playing the
longer the great patient war yes that's
yours okay the Dalai Lama wants to make
sure I speak with the current SI kyung
their term for a prime minister please
sit down is Tibet ever coming back
absolutely yeah you believe that
absolutely but everything suggests
otherwise no because you asked me this
question here in bodhgaya mm-hmm where
buddha did something impossible at an
Enlightenment and Buddhism is 2500 plus
years old communism is just what
hundreds of years all one-party rule is
less than hundred years old there is no
competition between the two we must have
dialogue between the invoice with daya
Lama and Chinese representative and
Tibetans should be granted in genuine
autonomy as per Chinese laws within
China but you know I exist in a
political world and I play hardball
Tibetans we see China in a different way
our perspectives very different we have
live side by side for thousands of years
so we kind of know them better than
anyone in the world so hence we don't
fear China we are not amazed by China we
know exactly what they're doing our time
will come our opportunity to come
the Prime Minister's optimism comes from
outside the political sphere he sees
this it seems as a war of ideas and
takes comfort from the longevity of the
Buddhist culture in a time when the
world seems to be in turmoil a turmoil
I've seen firsthand as a journalist in
Afghanistan and Iraq and beyond I have
to wonder can the Dalai Lama's message
of hope prevail